Kamala Harris our vice president she has
thoughts on our culture well I think
culture is
it is a reflection of our moment and our
time right and and and
present culture is the way we express
how we're feeling about the moment
and and we should always find times to
express how we feel about the moment
that is a reflection of Joy because
every you know
it comes in the morning
we have to find ways to also Express the
way we feel about the moment in terms of
just having language and and a
connection to how people are
experiencing life and I think about it
in that way too culture is the Norms
rituals and behaviors of a given people
that's the answer she was looking for